I was under the impression that
Christmas came but once a year so why
pray are the nation's shopkeepers
Hawking us turkey for our Easter tide
tables panettone stolen decorations
trees the sort of fair in fact you might
find in a traditional German Christmas
market
I don't dare switch on the TV in case
there's a gloopy John Lewis advert to
try to get us to give each other
Easter prezi's or an advert for eggs
without saying Easter on them or another
repeat of the pledge this is still a
Christian country the egg is a symbol of
Christ's resurrection Holy Week is the
most important Christian celebration of
the year of course we all love a chalky
egg but don't know Easter to become a
marketing shopping and eating
opportunity just devoid of ritual and
meaning now and as the Easter Bunny only
comes once a year I have got some
examples of Easter marketing for you
here we have and that's got no mention
of Easter on it who wants that one no
I've got something special for you I'm
giving it to our smartypants and this is
a website pink unicorn I mean that's
Easter to you as it's a unicorn I
thought we should give it to cow because
she still believes in brexit you want
this for your kids if this says the
eastern tiny writing a lot like really
but finally for June this is a proper
Easter egg which has got a book planing
the Easter story and the meaning of
Easter it's called the real Easter egg
it's literally the most worthy thing
you've ever seen it in there recently
what a pity can we put up putting
opportunities away yeah say we can talk
about the meeting mr. Rachel Rachel
where bah humbug you sound like Ebenezer
Scrooge in that introduction look you
know Esther is still about
religion it's still about Christ and the
resurrection but it's also an
opportunity for companies on the side to
peddle a bit of wear and make a bit of
profit especially if they've got stock
left cycling tag using turkeys those
turkeys are gonna rot unless they sell
them I mean look it's not actually as no
exaggeration they've introduced turkeys
for Easter hello goodness it is
apparently that's too much different
from a Christmas you see because that
would go to waste otherwise they're
trying to sell it and so you know I'm a
practicing one but this country's
becoming more and more secular so it
doesn't mean what it uses no not
necessarily I think it's something it
doesn't mean what it once did for a lot
of people why are we doing otherwise
what do you mean it's time for families
to come together
it's the anglo-saxon goddess posture the
goddess of fertility I'm on the loss of
her memory talking about the
commercialization of it the trouble is
that commercialize it only happens with
consent and people have to start using
faith in Christianity yeah the
manufacturers were allowed to rush in
and the problem the problem isn't it's
not isn't that Easter has been
commercialized
it's what what's important is that he
religion isn't putting out a strong
enough message to dads egg or a
propylene and that's thought that you
know in in the late 16th century baroque
churches were built to attract people to
come to the church it was a
commercialization of the religion if you
like and people have to come in their
page I have a solution to that and it's
a four-letter word and it begins with F
and I will tell you the solution just
about oh yes it's but for many reasons
so who thought brexit was the big debate
it's an exit this is what necessary UK
want to get across in our confectionary
archive we have examples and records of
thousands of Easter products from down
the decades most of them don't refer to
Easter explicitly on the packaging
chocolate eggs have been synonymous with
Easter and the Easter story since the
beginning of the last century so the
Association is an automatic one these
products are clear
made and sell specifically for the
Easter season the wording on these
products has changed very little over
time good point you make that people
don't go to church I respect the fact
you do do you know what I think is gone
out of church and that's fear the F
letter what the F word is yeah because I
think in some is the reason that I enjoy
and my late father was not a practicing
Catholic was a Catholic lady I'm with it
moments Cathy I love the sense of fear
in a Roman Catholic service in that you
yeah that you have to do that and that
you in a way that you might have been a
sinner and you have to become and I
think and I think the way we went down a
very dangerous and rather retro step
when we had vicars playing guitars and
yeah that's the words thank you happy
clappy vicars playing guitar I like a
bit of fear that if you don't behave
yourself you'll all go to hell lead up
to Easter I'm sure in yours it was six
weeks to torture it was lent you know
what you only ever got one of your mom
and dad and maybe one of your Nana and
that was that was the end of it there
was no big celebration or there the
kneeling little Stations of the Cross do
say the very big on Easter and they fit
into all their products during this
season that what what I will say is that
what swung be against your debate is
when I saw the Easter tree because
actually I thought it was like a
Christmas tree but they've actually
designed a tree that very much looks
like this that's lovely
because of the eggs now you know that
it's difficult to it's difficult to
criticize that because even though it's
a tree we associate trees at Christmas
is not recycled Christmas you know this
also puts a lot of pressure on families
I think as well you know Christmas is
really expensive for a lot of families
you're just getting over there and Wham
it's Easter again but not just the eggs
it's all of this nonsense that goes with
it as well so I think it's a massive
pressure on farms people try to get the
perfect Christmas now they're trying to
get the perfect Easter time well then of
course we have the Millennials jumping
on board we don't we have the Easter a
picado egg yeah I did think that what
this is
this is shown over that Easter weekend
as well but what is today what is the
official name of didn't know its laundy
Thursday what's tomorrow
Good Friday okay said 43% of young
people didn't believe in the
resurrection know which is my husband on
Maundy Thursday he was yes yes and then
what happened on Good Friday he walked
up the hill across mean fiction is a
sign of brilliance it's being lost
because of Carol's point yeah because of
the failure of the church yeah it's not
because companies that whose
responsibility it is a church is grown
because the number of Eastern European
that's not because of the indigenous
community so what you're saying is right
so we can link it to pressure you know
what I was saying societies becoming
more more secular or not Christian as a
Muslim what does Easter mean to you and
how do you celebrate what are the core
tenets so Muslims believe in Jesus as a
prophet now the old tenants of Islam
that it differs with over Christianity's
that they believe that Jesus wasn't
crucified but God basically saved his
prophet and apart from therefore the
Easter story is kind of it's not really
in sync
yeah but the reservoir the return of the
Messiah you believe we go back to that
right so so the bit that's missing is
the Easter bit which is why perhaps I'm
slightly indulgent with the chocolate
cuz it's like for me it is you know it's
always been a secular